Mckenzie was advising both the fox and
the hen house and getting paid by both
McKinsey also advises the U.S government
including hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of work for the Pentagon
according to an NBC News investigation
have you ever heard of a company called
McKinsey and a CO they're the oldest and
largest of the big three management
consulting firms and they work with
virtually every company you can think of
this includes everyone from American
Express and ATT to Citibank and General
Motors McKinsey also offers some of the
best salaries for college graduates and
offers them an exciting opportunity to
travel the world and work with the
largest companies but behind the hood
McKinsey isn't all that it's hyped up to
be for one their business is management
consulting which isn't all that
effective or useful if you're wondering
why companies hired them despite that
check out our video on that but being
ineffective isn't the only critique of
McKenzie if anything it's actually the
smallest critique the biggest red flag
is that they've been involved in the
biggest scandals of all time from Enron
and the 2008 financial crisis to the
opioid epidemic and election scandals
and those are just to name a few mckindy
has also played a role in most of the
scandals and the evil businesses that
Jake Tran has covered even including the
ones about authoritarian regimes like
Saudi Arabia and Russia ironically it
seems like they're much more effective
at helping shading Affairs projects than
they are when it comes to doing an
actual positive management consulting
but despite their large negative
influence they're rarely talked about on
the news or social media the fact that
they're completely privately owned it
just makes them even more discreet and
secretive but McKinsey and Co wasn't
always so shady like most companies
McKinsey was established with good
intentions and for many decades they had
a relatively clean record so here's the
story of how McKinsey and KOA became the
consultant at deserve hell
[Music]
foreign
dates all the way back to 1926 to a man
named James o McKinsey James was an
accounting professor at the University
of Chicago and he got the idea to create
McKinsey and KOA after witnessing a
bunch of inefficiencies across military
suppliers given that he was an
accounting professor he felt that he
could clean up their books and make
these suppliers a lot more efficient so
he went ahead and established an
accounting and management firm called
James o McKinsey and the company while
the firm carries James name to this day
James actually didn't play a very big
role in its growth or expansion largely
because he couldn't you see about 10
years after founding the company James
would be hit with a severe case of
pneumonia that took his life but on the
bright side it looks like James had
already hired a stark partner named
Marvin Bauer who could carry on his
legacy by trade Bauer was actually a
lawyer but he never really worked as a
lawyer given that he joined McKenzie a
few years after graduating and he
basically became the father of the
company Bauer established much of
mckinsey's corporate culture and created
policies that are now used around the
world like the up or out policy as the
name suggests if you don't get promoted
within a certain time frame you get
fired this ensures that no employee is
stagnating or getting too comfortable
but this policy has come under Fire
during recent times as it also
encourages backstabbing and the
corporate politics but anyway McKenzie
would it drift away from its accounting
roots not long after James's death in
fact the company would physically split
up into three different companies in
1939 called the Scoville Wellington and
Company McKinsey and Company and the
McKinsey Kieran company the accounting
practice would be shifted to Scoville
which left the other companies with the
classic management consulting while this
division robbed Mackenzie of much of its
subject matter expertise McKenzie
retained much of the military to supply
relationships that James had established
and this was extraordinarily valuable
given that World War II and the Cold War
were just around the corner McKinsey
became the go-to consultants for
governments defense contractors and
Military organizations around the world
which allowed for exponential growth
throughout the 40s and 50s they went
from 88 consultants in 1951 to over 200
Consultants by the 1960s they were also
able to establish a massive base of
operations in Europe with offices in
London Paris and Amsterdam despite all
this growth power never forgot about his
employees in fact he would constantly
work to make sure his employees were
well taken care of for example in 1951
he established a profit sharing program
and in 1956 he would shift 100 of the
company's ownership to the firm's
employees and that's how it is to this
day but while things were developing
great within McKinsey the same could it
not be said about the industry and The
Business this as a whole as the era of
the red skier came to an end in the late
1960s so did the era of the original
mckinsient go
while McKinsey was highly sought after
in the early days due to their services
being novel and unique the same and
couldn't not be said by the 1970s you
see it after McKinsey ditched their
accounting routes they never focused on
another technical discipline and while
this worked out early on as the industry
matured at McKinsey Services became a
less and less valuable most companies
preferred to hire technical consultants
with strong backgrounds in engineering
information technology and enterprise
resource planning as opposed to
generalists this is why technical
consulting firms like Accenture and the
tcsf-4 outperformed their legacy
consultants in recent decades new
competition and management consulting
from firms like Boston Consulting Group
and Bain and Company didn't help the
situation either in fact in 1971
mckinsey's own internal commission found
that McKinsey had become too focused on
Geographic expansion and lacked adequate
industry knowledge the commission
advised that McKinsey slow its growth
and develop industry Specialties ideally
McKinsey would have specialized in the
rapidly growing tech industry but
instead they decided to specialize in
various management consulting niches
this included sectors such as strategy
operations and organization while these
sectors better defined what McKinsey was
offering it didn't exactly change what
they were offering so they continued to
face many of the same issues you could
say that McKenzie had trouble pitching
their value proposition to companies but
they would eventually figure it out
after they analyzed what company leaders
truly wanted company leaders didn't
necessarily want a strategy or branding
Consulting what they really wanted was
growth happy shareholders a good
reputation and less responsibility
McKinsey couldn't guarantee growth or
happy shareholders but they could help
leaders achieve a good reputation and
less responsibility by becoming
scapegoats are you the leader of a
Fortune 500 company that needs to make a
bunch of hard choices well hi Russ and
will probably tell you to make the same
choices is but we can make it a win-win
scenario for you if the choices end up
working well you can take the praise and
glory if they don't work on the other
hand you can blame us and walk away
relatively clean for many Legacy leaders
this is a deal that's too good to turn
down and in modern times this is very
much the real appeal of management
Consultants while this turned out to be
quite lucrative and in demand McKenzie
had regressed from being accounting
experts to becoming generalists to
becoming scapegoats but this was just
the beginning of their Devolution
remember how we talked about company
leaders having to make hard choices well
these hard choices didn't just include
completing layoffs or shutting down in
the underperforming sector many of these
choices related to truly nefarious
activities
foreign
activities and evil projects like Enron
if you're not familiar with Enron it was
the largest accounting product of all
time leading to shareholder losses of 74
billion dollars the first thing we
should note is that the Mastermind of
this Scandal Jeff's killing it was
formerly a McKinsey consultant for 21
years but that's just the beginning of
McKenzie's connection to Enron Enron
would use Mackenzie on 20 different
projects and the two companies were so
close that McKinsey Consultants had
quote used Enron as their sandbox
McKenzie wouldn't never be convicted for
their connection to Enron and while you
can ride off and run as a one-off
connection McKenzie has so many such
connections that it's hard to write off
everything as just a coincidence which
brings us into our next exhibit which is
the 2008 financial crisis McKinsey is
Iconic for encouraging Banks to
securitize mortgage assets and to fund
their balance sheet using that these
practices are what would eventually make
the Global Financial system insolvent
leading to the crisis during this time
period mckinsia also advised financial
institutions to deliberately screw over
end users for example they advised
Allstate Insurance to purposely give low
offers to claimants the idea was that
fighting this Injustice would be so
expensive that lawyers would refuse to
help these clients moving on we have
likely their most disgusting Scandal as
it didn't just screw over people's
finances it literally screwed over their
lives as their next Scandal relates to
the opioid epidemic McKinsey created a
strategy for pharmaceuticals that would
quote unquote turbocharged sales of
Oxycontin this essentially consisted of
McKinsey advising pharmaceutical
companies how they could actively
circumvent opioid regulations and
deliberately encourage and to get people
addicted for victims of addiction it's
common for their close family if they
have any to try to talk to them and
persuade them from an emotional
standpoint if you've ever been in this
situation and you've had trouble getting
to the victim well you can blame
MacKenzie because they were literally
proposing strategies to counter the
emotional messages from mothers with the
teenagers who overdosed on oxycontin
they were also proposing that
pharmaceutical companies pay pharmacies
a rebate based on how many overdoses and
addictions they caused I mean they
literally had it down to a science in
2019 they projected that 2 400 CVS
customers would have become addicted and
that each event which is what they
called it deserved a rebate of 14 810
this meant that Purdue Pharma would have
to pay CVS 36.8 million dollars that
year for their work fortunately these
scumbags got exposed but they would walk
away with the settlement of just 573
million dollars which is ridiculous
because this is not the type of crime
that you get find for it's the type of
climate that you get shut down for yet
here we are at least with this one
McKenzie wasn't directly causing Dent
with these next few cases well you can
be the judge
Mackenzie and Saudi Arabia are basically
best friends given that McKinsey has
completed 600 projects for Saudi Arabia
between 2011 and 2016 alone Saudi Arabia
is an authoritarian regime that doesn't
like its citizens dissenting with its
leaders so naturally many of McKenzie's
projects have to do with silencing
dissenters now let me be clear McKinsey
only identifies such individuals they're
not involved in what happens next but
when you know that there's a good chance
that the people that you identify will
be unfairly arrested if not oft it's
quite immoral that you continue
Consulting with said government Saudi
Arabia isn't their only authoritarian
client either another authoritarian
client is of course China a great
example of their indifferent and
soulless behavior is their actions
during the peak of the euchar genocide
in China back in December of 2018
Mackenzie hosted a lavish company
Retreat alongside Chinese officials
while thousands of you guys for being
detained and oft just miles away
McKinsey received quite a bit of
backlash for this Behavior but it
doesn't look like they've changed their
weights you know how virtually every
Western Corporation has withdrawn from
Russia due to the war while it looks
like McKinsey didn't get the memo as
it's reported that McKenzie has been
offering consulting services to the
Russian state-owned Enterprise rostock
who is responsible for manufacturing
missile engines in the Ukraine war what
makes this even more unethical is that
McKinsey was Consulting with the
Pentagon at the same time Mackenzie also
has a history of scandals with
Democratic countries for example it's
alleged that McKinsey helped the Gupta
family to position corrupted individuals
across the South African government
similarly and it's also alleged that
McKenzie helped French president
Emmanuel macron to bypass campaign
Finance laws and finally it also alleged
that McKinsey has been helping Canada
Implement immigration policies that
don't have the Public's best interest in
mind
foreign
hearing all this I don't think I need to
explain the title well McKinsey started
off with good intentions of improving
corporate accounting and management
efficiency they slowly saw their value
proposition declined decadent after a
decade instead of pivoting to the
technical space which was the
up-and-coming Consulting industry they
decided to turn to the dark side they
became corporate scapegoats and secret
advisors on nefarious strategies these
include everything from financial fraud
and corporate scandals to ruining
countless lives and causing deaths yet
given that McKinsey is just a consulting
firm and it doesn't make the final
decision they're rarely held accountable
and even when they are their punishment
is laughable and that's why McKinsey and
KOA are the Consultants that deserve
hell but that's just what I think do you
think McKinsey deserves hell comment
that down below also drop a like if you
think McKenzie should be held
accountable and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
together ideas and to consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]